we're going to begin with breaking news
that could mean trouble for one of
america's closest middle east allies
the united nations report on the killing
of washington post contributor jamal
khashoggi
recommends an investigation of saudi
arabia's powerful crown prince mohammed
bin salman
his role has been a source of
speculation since khashoggi was murdered
the report says quote there is credible
evidence meriting further investigation
holly williams has covered this case
from the very beginning and she's in
istanbul
where khashoggi was killed at the saudi
consulate back in october
so holly good morning to you but what
does the report say warning this
report will undoubtedly infuriate the
government of saudi arabia
mainly because of that key headline that
quote
there is credible evidence warranting
further investigation
that crown prince mohammed bin salman
was involved in the killing of jamal
khashoggi
the saudis have consistently denied that
even as they've changed their story
more than once about what actually
happened and despite widespread
suspicions that the crown prince is
implicated
just a reminder of the facts here jamal
khashoggi a saudi journalist commentator
and critic of the government
visited the saudi consulate here in
istanbul turkey in october last year
never to be seen again at first the
saudi government denied all involvement
then more than two weeks later they
finally admitted he'd been killed inside
the consulate
they claimed in a physical altercation
then
weeks later they said he'd actually been
killed by a lethal injection in a rogue
operation
jamal shokoji's body has never been
found the un report also found that the
trial in saudi arabia of 11 suspects
fails to meet procedural standards and
should be suspended
it's being held behind closed doors and
the fear is that some of those suspects
could be put to death without the
opportunity to tell their stories to the
outside world
tony holly what does this mean for the
u.s relationship with saudi arabia
i think the key thing tony is that it
increases the pressure on the us
government
uh to take a tougher line with the
saudis uh beyond the sanctions on
individuals uh that are already in place
and specifically with respect to the
crown prince mohammed bin salman
all right holly williams for us in
istanbul holly thank you very much